And welcome to the session on rare
cancer drug development.
My name is Diane Pulte. I'm a clinical reviewer with the FDA
in the Division of Hematologic Malignancies 1, which
covers leukemia.
These are my disclosures. I have no disclosures.
The perspectives shared are those of the FDA staff and the panelists
participating, not necessarily those of their respective organizations,
and investigational drugs
will be discussed.
So just give a quick outline of the session.
After the introduction, we'll have talks on challenges and opportunities in
development of medications for rare diseases.
Martha Donahue will present the FDA perspective, and then Eric Padron will
present a perspective on
development in CMML, and then Rachel Groseman will tell us about
a successful development program.
We'll have the panel discussion with Lisa Ranka,
Josh Bilenker, and Nicole Andrews, and then we'll follow up with questions.
Okay. Without further ado, Martha.
Trip over something.
Good afternoon, everybody. My name is Martha Donahue.
I'm a pediatric oncologist by training, and I've worked at the FDA for
about 15-plus years now. I currently serve as the associate
director for Pediatric Oncology and Rare Cancers in the Oncology Center
of Excellence. And it's such a pleasure to be here.
Thank you all for joining.
That's me, and I'm going to give a little bit of a 15-minute or so talk
on the regulatory perspective on rare cancer drug development.
We've already done that.
Here's an outline of what I plan to cover.
First, I'll provide an overview of the role of FDA's Oncology Center of
Excellence, or OCE, and briefly describe some of the existing
challenges to rare cancer drug development.
Next, we'll discuss some of FDA's regulatory incentives and
expedited programs to help encourage and support rare cancer
drug development. And then I'll describe the evidentiary
standards for FDA approval of drugs and biological products, and
discuss potential regulatory flexibilities that we can apply to
help hasten and make drug development for rare cancers more
feasible, as well as some trial design and conduct
considerations. And before wrapping up with some
key takeaways, I'll point out a few FDA resources to support rare
cancer drug development.
This slide provides a high-level overview of FDA's Oncology Center of
Excellence, or OCE. And OCE unites experts
across the FDA to foster development of medical products for
cancers. These experts work in three different centers in the
FDA: the Center for Drug Evaluation and Research, or CDER,
which
provides regulatory oversight of development for small molecules and
antibody-based cancer therapies; the Center for Biologics
Evaluation and Research, or CBER, which regulates the more
complex biological products, including cell and gene therapies,
as well as therapeutic vaccines; and the Center for Devices and
Radiologic Health, or CDRH, which regulates the therapeutic devices,
diagnostic devices, and in particular, when we think about for
targeted therapies in oncology, the companion diagnostic tests,
which are often used to select patients for targeted
therapies.
As depicted on this slide, and I think all of us know all too well,
there are many challenges to successful drug development
for rare cancers, which can make drug development in this space a risky
proposition for pharmaceutical companies.
And just a few include small patient numbers and geographic
dispersion, which can make patient accrual more difficult.
The natural history of rare cancers are often not well described.
We're still learning every day little new things about all
cancers and rare cancers as well. We often have an
insufficient understanding of cancer pathophysiology and molecular
characteristics of these cancers, limited or lack of
timely access to molecular testing for many patients.
There's also genotypic and phenotypic heterogeneity that's also
characteristic of all cancers, but for rare cancers, those have even
more difficult implications in terms of feasibility.
There, of course, all of this rarity brings into play trial design complexities,
including lack of viable therapies, sometimes for control treatment
arms, reluctance to randomize in some settings as
well, for lots of reasons. All of this can
sometimes depress commercial interest in developing
new drugs for rare cancers. And there are others that I'm sure you can all think
of as well. The good news that I think is if we all work together, we can start
tackling these issues. We've been doing this for a while.
We're going to continue to do so, and I'm looking forward to hearing some ideas
from all of you and the panelists in the next couple of minutes.
There are regulatory incentives in place to help tip the balance in favor of
drug development for rare cancers, and some of these are on this
slide, and these include orphan drug designation, which uses the definition
of rare disease defined by the Orphan Drug Act of a prevalence of less
than 200,000 patients in the United States.
To me, 200,000 seems like an awfully large number because, as we know, many rare
cancers and subsets of common cancers based
on molecular characteristics fall far behind those numbers, and with
increasing rarity, of course, the challenges can sometimes enlarge as
well.
However, that being said, orphan drug designation does provide economic
incentives for the development of orphan products by providing tax
credits for qualified clinical trials, exemption from prescription
drug user fees for FDA review, and seven years of marketing
exclusivity following approval.
The Office of Orphan Products Development at the FDA also offers 5
to 12 new clinical trial grants for orphan products
annually through a competitive process, and they've provided grants for several
clinical trials for adult and pediatric rare
cancers.The Rare Disease Priority Review Voucher
Program, I'm happy to say, was recently reauthorized, and it
confers transferable priority review vouchers following the original approval of a
drug to treat a rare pediatric disease.
I've heard anecdotally from stakeholders that this program provides meaningful
incentives to companies, particularly small pharma, for the development
of drugs to treat pediatric cancers.
And several vouchers have been awarded following approval of
products to treat pediatric cancers, including the recent award
of a pediatric voucher for dardavirpan following
the 2025 approval of the drug for the treatment of
H3K27M mutant diffuse midline glioma.
The Best Pharmaceutical for Children Act request process provides additional
incentives for development of drugs for pediatric cancers by
conferring six months additional exclusivity to the active moiety in
return for submission of reports from voluntarily conducted pediatric
studies outlined in the written request.
As we know, despite these incentives, there's still a high unmet need for new drugs
to treat patients with rare cancers, and in particular, those that do not
share targets with more common cancers.
FDA also has expedited programs, which are intended to
facilitate and speed up development and review of drugs that address
unmet medical needs in the treatment of serious and life-threatening
conditions, such as rare cancers, and it is very typical
for rare cancer drug development programs to take advantage of one or more of
these programs. We encourage sponsors to consider
applying for these programs early in development,
as early as possible, and we'll discuss accelerated approval shortly
in a bit more detail. But in the interest of time, I'll just note that
Fast Track and Breakthrough Therapy designations provide opportunities for
increased interaction with the agency, particularly experts in the
agency who are pretty experienced throughout drug development,
as well as rolling review in the case of Fast Track designation.
And priority review shortens our application review time by four
months, although I will note that often our reviews are much shorter than what
is required.
I'll move on to the requirements for FDA approval of drugs and
biologics.
The requirements for FDA approval are outlined in the Food, Drug, and Cosmetic
Act. A drug's effectiveness must be established by what we term
substantial evidence, which consists of adequate and well-controlled investigations
that are performed by qualified experts.
And the information from these
investigations should provide data that is sufficient to form the basis
for a fair and responsible conclusion by experts that the drug
has the effect that it claims to have.
In our case, that the drug or biologic is effective in treating cancer.
One thing to note is that this standard applies to both common and rare
cancers. The evidentiary requirements are the same
for us in order to make an approval decision.
It's not that there's a lesser bar for rare cancers compared to less rare
cancers. Although not on this slide, we also have to conclude
that the overall balance of safety and effectiveness is such that the
benefits of the drug outweigh the risks.
There are two approval pathways for drugs and biologics: accelerated
approval and regular or traditional approval.
Accelerated approval allows for earlier approval of drugs for serious and
life-threatening conditions that address unmet medical needs, and the
guiding principle for approval is the same for both approval
pathways. But there are a few differences to highlight between the two.
While there are no requirements for a product to be better than available
therapies for regular approval, for a drug to receive accelerated
approval, it must provide a meaningful therapeutic benefit over available
therapies. Accelerated approval is also based on an intermediate
clinical endpoint that is likely to predict clinical benefit, rather than a
direct measure of clinical benefit, such as survival.
Traditional approval is based on an endpoint that demonstrates direct clinical
benefit,
as I just said, such as overall survival or some improvement in patient-related
symptoms would be another. In oncology, we often use
intermediate clinical endpoints that directly measure the tumor itself, such
as overall response rate or progression-free survival.
And these endpoints can be used to support either accelerated or regular
approval, depending upon the context.
Oncology, by far, has the most accelerated approvals among medical
specialties, accounting for about 80% of accelerated approvals by
FDA in the last decade. And this reflects not only the urgent
nature of cancer treatment and high unmet medical need, but also the
field's advancement in identifying meaningful biomarkers and intermediate
endpoints.
Now that I've talked a little bit about the requirements for approval, I'd like to
describe how our regulations mandate that FDA exert
flexibility in our assessment of whether the regulatory standards for approval
are met, taking into account unmet medical need, among other
factors.
As you can see, based on the first regulatory citation, we're required to
exercise our judgment at the FDA to determine the type and
quantity of information that the applicant should provide in their
application to support approval.
Not only that, but under the Code of Federal Regulations, for drugs
intended to treat life-threatening and severely debilitating
diseases, such as rare cancers, we acknowledge that it is
appropriate to exercise broad flexibility in applying the
statutory standards while preserving appropriate guarantees of
safety and effectiveness.
There are several ways that we
at the FDA can potentially support
more flexibility, as listed on this slide.
We have exerted flexibility in terms of the
number of trials required, the design of these trials, trial
endpoints, as well as statistical considerations of trials supporting
approval when
appropriate.Under certain
circumstances, FDA can conclude that one adequate and well-controlled
clinical investigation, plus confirmatory evidence, is sufficient to
establish effectiveness. And confirmatory evidence can take a number of
forms, including things such as mechanistic or pharmacodynamic
evidence,
clinical evidence from related indications, evidence from relevant animal
models, and so on. In a recent "New
England Journal of Medicine" article, Doctors Prasad and Makary
described one pivotal trial as the new default
option for FDA approval,
and also noted that in some fields, such as oncology, single
trials have supported the majority of drug approvals.
In other words, approval decisions based on the result of one adequate and
well-controlled trial are the rule rather than the exception
in oncology.
Additionally, data from single-arm trials have often been used in oncology to
support approval of drugs as single agents.
Particularly in the refractory setting, we have approved single-agent
treatments for both common and rare cancers based upon trials with primary
endpoints of overall response rate, as well as durability of response.
And these response rate endpoints can be interpreted in single-arm trials
because cancers don't typically regress on their own without effective
treatment. However, there are real limitations to single-arm designs that we
should keep in mind that can lead to uncertainty in the assessment of safety and
effectiveness. In other words, even for the drug development in rare cancers,
single-arm designs are not always the ideal approach.
With single-arm designs in rare cancer safety databases, as we know, are often
small, and assessment of whether the drug causes the adverse events seen in the
trial can be difficult with non-randomized designs.
Additionally, important time to event endpoints such as survival and time to tumor
progression are generally not interpretable due to confounding factors.
And another important limitation is that the clinical implications of drugs that
have low overall response rates are not easily understood, and it can be
difficult to determine whether the observed responses are predictive of whether a
patient's benefiting from treatment or not.
For these reasons, we do recommend careful consideration of whether randomized
designs are the most appropriate design in rare cancers and,
of course, more common cancers.
There are many approaches to trial design conduct and statistical analysis
that can be leveraged to help facilitate development of new therapies for rare
cancers, and I put a few on this slide.
This includes seamless designs, use of expansion cohorts, platform trials,
incorporation of adaptive design elements into clinical trials,
Bayesian statistics, as well as model-informed approaches,
and careful use of clinical outcome assessment endpoints as well.
We emphasize the importance of patient-informed drug development,
consideration of multi-regional trials, and thinking about
incorporation of pragmatic clinical trial design elements to make trials
more patient-centric.
I've provided a few relevant resources on this slide for you
to review at your leisure, including FDA guidances and a few of the many
OCE programs and initiatives that can be leveraged to support cancer drug
development. More information on these guidances and OCE programs can be
found online.
I'd like to briefly call your attention to funding opportunities for extramural
research, including broad agency announcements, notice of funding
opportunities, and the previously mentioned orphan products grants.
And please visit the OCE Scientific Collaborative website for additional
information if you're interested.
I'd also like to call out my friends and colleagues at Project Facilitate, which is
an OCE program. It's basically a call center to help guide physicians who are
seeking single patient INDs for expanded access use of investigational
products for their patients. This is a really useful team that can
help guide you through the process if you're uncertain how to do it, or even if you
have experience. And they're very approachable, so please do
take advantage of the resources there if you have that
situation.
And I'd like to leave you guys with just a few key takeaways to summarize my talk.
Development of drugs to treat rare cancers can be challenging, but we at the FDA
have numerous resources that can be leveraged to help overcome these obstacles, and
we are really interested in working with you to help figure out the best
development programs for drugs for the specific rare cancer you're
interested in.
FDA approval does require substantial evidence of effectiveness, irrespective of
cancer prevalence. And randomized trials should always be considered,
especially early in the drug development process for rare cancers,
where every patient's data matters.
Well, it matters no matter what, but you know what I'm saying.
We have to be especially thoughtful about rare cancers.
We can exercise broad flexibility in applying the statutory standards
for safety and effectiveness when warranted, and we are eager to discuss
these approaches with people interested in drug development for rare
cancers, in particular, understanding that no one size fits all approach can
be applied. We do recommend early and frequent interaction with
stakeholders to discuss development for rare cancers, and we do
invite and encourage industry sponsors to bring
in representatives from every stakeholder group into these meetings,
representatives from patient advocacy, the investigators, as well
as the industry sponsor representatives, because that can really help promote
clearer communication and more productive discussions.
I'd like to thank the AACR staff for
helping to support us in this meeting, as well as my colleagues at the
FDA, and thank all of you for being here, of course.
Please do reach out to me, or the OCE Rare Cancer Program if you have
questions or needs. And I also wanted to let you know that we are interested in
hiring talented people who want to join our team.
So if you are interested or know somebody who might be, please feel free to reach
out to us on this email, and thank you for your attention, and I will turn it
back to my colleague, Diane.
Thank you, Martha. Next, I have Eric Padron who will
speak on barriers to clinical development of therapeutics for chronic
myelomonocytic leukemia.
Okay. Good afternoon, everybody. Can you guys hear me okay?
Well, it's an honor to be here. I'd like to start by thanking
Diane and Martha, and the FDA
for the kind invitation. I'd like to thank
AACR for sponsoring this important topic.
And I'd like to start by saying, at least for me, one of the most compelling
reasons why this is important. If you look at, for example,
the National Cancer Institute definition of a rare cancer,
30% of all patients with cancer have a rare cancer.
And while there are many flavors of this,
it becomes very clear that the barriers that we're going to talk about
today matter for a lot of people.
I'm going to tell you about one of these rare cancers, chronic myelomonocytic
leukemia. I'll give you a little
primer on the disease and its clinical development.
And I'll warn you that this is a journey that's far from over, but I hope that
some of the barriers that we've encountered help fuel the discussion.
So,
this is my disclosure slide.
Okay, so what is CMML? So CMML is a
disease, and the pathologic hallmark of CMML is a
classical monocytosis. What I mean by that is, in humans, there are three
types of monocytes: classical, intermediate, and non-classical.
And in CMML, as compared to normal, you see a highly
restricted classical monocytosis.
Patients with CMML have a homogenous spectrum of
mutations, but unfortunately, and I'll discuss that in
a minute,
those homogenous mutations are in disparate pathways.
So we're talking about
DNA methylation, histone modifications, RAS pathway signaling,
splicing. So very few number of mutations, but
disparate biology.
We've shown a long time ago that maybe one of the convergent
mechanisms is hypersensitivity to a cytokine called GM-CSF,
and I'll tell you why I think that's important for the future of CMML drug
development.
These patients not only have a severe cancer that is
life-threatening, but they have really dramatic
impairments in quality of life. And this could be very
similar to those that we know in other chronic myeloid neoplasms, like
myelofibrosis, to include massive splenomegaly, weight loss, et cetera.
Unlike myelofibrosis and some of the other
chronic hematologic malignancies, CMML is an aggressive
disease with a median survival of, unfortunately, 32 months.
And unlike its related disease, myelodysplastic syndrome, there are
no
FDA-approved drugs that alter the natural history of the
disease.
Now, that's not to say that there aren't any FDA-approved drugs for CMML, and
it's a little bit of a unique clinical development history.
So this is the timeline. So I can make the font really big because
there's not that many things that
have been developed. But the moral of this story is that really
azacitidine, decitabine,
and oral decitabine in Covi were all approved really
in a clinical trial
that included MDS patients. In fact, if you look at the azacitidine
trial, the pivotal trial in 2001, there were only
11 patients with CMML in that study.
And so there really hasn't been any CMML specific drugs approved to
date.
So as I thought about why, I organized it into
four categories. I'm sure there's more.
And I'll talk a little bit about that.
So there's the economic case, there's the biology, which I hinted to,
there's can you even do a Phase III study, and
then what are the endpoints and what is the pathway?
So
let's talk a little bit about the economic case, and this is what I always talk to
my industry collaborators about is, yes, CMML is
rare, just like any hematologic malignancy in adults, but it's
not that rare. And if you look at its incidence, it's comparable to
other myeloproliferative neoplasms that have had successful drug
approvals. The challenge is that the prevalence of these
diseases is far fewer. But like we've learned in chronic myeloid
leukemia and other diseases, if you have effective therapy, that
therapy would augment the prevalence of the disease.
So to build on that, I took a little bit of a deep dive and
asked how many diseases that have similar
incidence have FDA-approved drugs.
I'm sure this list is not exhaustive, but here's a list of
diseases that have
comparable or smaller incidence.
And these are the FDA-approved drugs that have been approved.
I won't go over all of them, but I'll just highlight one, PNH,
for example. There are six FDA-approved drugs, and it's a disease that
is, at best, comparable, if not more
rare than CMML. So why?
So as you take a deeper dive into these diseases, what you
find is there are one of two things.
Either there is a clear somatic mutation that is
targetable in the vast majority of cases.
You can see that in PNH, you can see it in Hairy cell, you can see that in
Waldenstrom's, you can see it in systemic mastocytosis, you could see that
in GIST.
And in those that don't have a targetable mutation
in, say, over 80% of cases, there happens to be
convergent biology. So JAK-STAT signaling in MPNs, for
exampleMerkel cell polyomavirus,
CD123 expression, and BPDCN. So these are all convergent
mechanisms that make a rare cancer not that
rare because it doesn't need to be sliced from a therapeutic standpoint
in many ways.
So what are we doing in CMML? And I broadly
categorized the preclinical landscape of CMML into two
categories. The first is the mutation-directed therapies.
Of course, that makes it hard because it's a rare disease, and then this is a
subset of a rare disease. But there are ways to move
these therapies forward that we can talk about in the session.
But what I'll just highlight is one study.
This work was led by Julia Maxson at OHSU, and
she focused on a mutation in a gene called SETBP1, and
this gene's mutated in about 15% of cases with
CMML and almost never in other
diseases. And doing really exciting
preclinical work, she found that mutated SETBP1
interacts with
missed acetyltransferases and that targeting KAT6 and 7
could be a viable strategy. So this is just one example of where I think it all
starts, which is the biology and identifying novel therapeutic
vulnerabilities.
But again, one of the things that is also important is to really try and find
convergent biology, especially in rare cancers, because there's just not
enough patients to slice the entire pie.
And one of the things, as I mentioned earlier, could be the hyperactivity or the
hyperactivity of GM-CSF signaling.
And so what this is aimed to depict is that just like
other myeloid diseases, CMML is a disease of the stem cell
in which pre-leukemic somatic mutations occur, so-called clonal
hematopoiesis. And then as the disease
evolves, there becomes a expansion of
cells that are very sensitive to GM-CSF.
And the question is, can this be therapeutically targeted?
And the short answer is we think so.
So these are two clinical trials that have already been completed,
single-arm studies, which show that perhaps either by its upstream
kinase, JAK2, in the context of ruxolitinib, or at the level
of a neutralizing antibody in
lenzilumab, there is now proof of concept that targeting
GM-CSF signaling could lead to a
disease-modifying therapy in CMML, and
not just in one genetic subset. So we're excited about this and
hopefully these things will be developed further.
And then
can Phase III studies be done? That's a question that I'm always
asked, and I always start by saying, because there's such an opportunity,
because there are not many options for these patients, even though it's
rare, the clinical trials that
are designed for these diseases in fact accrue quite quickly.
So this is a Phase III study that was completed by the
GFM group led by Raphael Itzkenson.
So these were all sites in Europe and Paris, and they
randomized patients to either receive Dacogen
or Hydrea, about 84, 86 per group.
And their accrual time from start to finish was 18 months.
Now, unfortunately, this was a negative study,
but it shows clearly that with just a handful of centers, these studies
can be done.
This is another example just presented a few months ago at the American Society of
Hematology meeting, that Dan Weissman and colleagues from the UK
randomized 50 and 26 patients to receive
727 or hydroxyurea respectively.
And their accrual finished four months early, 18
months total. So these can be done.
These are rare diseases, but when you don't have a disease or a
disease-modifying therapy, there's a tremendous
opportunity to accrue quickly.
So what about endpoints? And I think this is among the more important topics to
discuss. And the short answer in CMML is we're trying.
So there were response criteria that
were established in 2015. They're being updated
now by Mike Savona, Doug Trembley, Tony Hunter, and others.
But the biggest challenge here is that it is among the most
clinically heterogeneous diseases.
So I hope we get a chance to talk about this in the panel, but the right endpoint
in diseases that are this heterogeneous have to do with the
specific drug itself and what we think that biology of where
that drug is going to do which will dictate endpoints in
future studies, and so that becomes quite challenging, and hopefully we can
talk about some ideas on how to overcome that barrier.
So I just want to summarize that we think that there are four barriers
that slow clinical drug development in CMML and probably other rare cancers,
but they're being addressed. And so I just wanted to put a plug for Blood Cancers
United, who have put tremendous amount of resources in
CMML research and advocacy
to show that these drugs can be done, to show that the true incidence
of CMML is comparable to a variety of other
cancers in which drugs have been approved, and to show that there's an economic
case. I think where it all starts
is the preclinical studies to understand the convergent
biology as well as a mutationally directed biology that can be
therapeutically exploited.
And then the feasibility of Phase III trials in the United
States remains to be
formally tested, but if they can do it in the UK and they can do it in France, I
think we can do it here.
And last, the endpoints, which I think is the most difficult one.
New response criteria are being established, but I think it'll
takea very detailed case-by-case analysis
between the sponsor, the investigator, and the FDA to
determine the right endpoint for the right drug for the
right set of patients with CMML.
So my prediction is, and I always keep saying this, let's just get one.
Once we get that first approval, I think the roadmap will be
set. I think there will be some certainty into what is the
pathway forward for both investigators and industry.
And I really do think many will follow after that.
And our hope is that these barriers will be
pushed away so we can have new therapies in CMML. And thank you for your attention.
Nice job.
Thank you, Rick.
Next, Rachel Grisham will present a talk on development
of the first FDA-approved treatment for women with low-grade
serous ovarian cancer.
Thanks, Dan. I'm so happy to be here today, and before we go to our panel
discussion, I hope we're going to end on a high point here, talking
about what I think is truly a huge success story, and to tell you
about the development of this first treatment that was FDA approved for women with
low-grade serous ovarian cancer, in part because of many of the
programs that Martha described to us at the beginning of this session.
These are my disclosures. My name is Rachel Grisham, and I'm a
Gynecologic Medical Oncologist at Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer Center
in New York.
So when I first started as a medical oncologist, we really thought about ovarian
cancer as epithelial ovarian cancer, the common type of ovarian
cancer arising from the outside of the ovary, and then some rare
parenchymal tumors like sex cord stromal tumors and germ cell
tumors.
But over the course of the past 15 years, in large part
due to the routine use of comprehensive sequencing, first in the
laboratory and now in routine clinical practice, we've come to
realize that epithelial ovarian cancer is really a group
of histologically and molecularly distinct diseases
which warrant individualized treatment.
The most common of these is high-grade serous ovarian cancer.
This accounts for about 70% of cases of epithelial ovarian
cancer. We now realize that this type of cancer actually usually
originates in the fallopian tube and spreads to the
ovary. These are rapidly dividing cells, and about a quarter of
our patients with high-grade serous ovarian cancer will have a germline or somatic
BRCA mutation, and about 50% of these patients will have
homologous recombination deficiency.
And then we have rarer subtypes of epithelial ovarian cancer,
such as endometrioid and clear cell ovarian cancer, that we now
realize actually most frequently develop from endometriosis
and therefore have a molecular profile more similar to that of endometrial
cancer, with PI3 kinase mutations, PTEN loss,
ARID1A mutations, and sometimes these tumors are MSI high.
And now we realize that mucinous ovarian cancer is actually an
occult GI primary in 50% of cases. So actually
an appendiceal, small intestine, or pancreatic cancer that has
metastasized to the ovary and is really best treated with
GI regimens. But what we're going to talk about today is
low-grade serous ovarian cancer.
This accounts for about 8 to 10% of epithelial ovarian cancer
cases. Unfortunately, the majority of women with this disease
present with advanced metastatic stage III or IV disease when they're
first diagnosed. And this cancer disproportionately
affects young women. More than 20% of our patients with low-grade
serous ovarian cancer are diagnosed before the age of 40.
Many of my patients are diagnosed in their teens or early 20s.
These are slower growing tumors, but because of that, they're less sensitive to
traditional chemotherapy. Response rates to
chemotherapy in the first-line setting are less than 25%
and rapidly fall down to the single digits in the recurrent setting.
These tumors do not have BRCA mutations or homologous
recombination deficiency, but we do now understand that the
majority of these tumors are driven by alterations in the MAP
kinase pathway, most commonly KRAS mutations, which are found
in about a third of patients with this disease.
Because of this, there was early interest in the use of MEK inhibitors to try to
treat patients with low-grade serous ovarian cancer.
And two prior large Phase III studies have successfully been
performed in women with recurrent low-grade serous ovarian
cancer. One of these was called GOG 281, and the other one was
called the MILO study. Both of these looked at the use of
single-agent MEK inhibitors versus physician's choice of therapy
for women with recurrent low-grade serous ovarian cancer.
These did show initial promising response with the use of single-agent MEK
inhibitor, with a response rate of 16% for
benimetinib and 26% for trametinib, but these were
limited by toxicity. Ultimately, about a third of patients
treated with continuous single-agent MEK inhibitor discontinued treatment due
to toxicity.
Ultimately, neither of these studies led to FDA approval of MEK inhibitors for
low-grade serous ovarian cancer.
But ultimately, actually, both of these agents were NCCN compendium
listed for treatment of the disease due to lack of effective therapies.
So we really wanted to build on this initial efficacy seen with
single-agent MEK inhibitors and try to decrease toxicity
by using combination therapy that would more effectively target that
pathway, but intermittent dosing to decrease
toxicity.Avutametinib is a first-in-class
RAF/MEK clamp, and defactinib is an oral Fak
inhibitor. The combination of avutametinib and
defactinib with intermittent dosing in the phase one
FRAME study showed very promising response rates
across multiple solid tumors, but in particular
for women with low-grade serous ovarian cancer, where the response
rate was greater than 40% and with durable
responses that lasted a median of 27 months.
Based on these promising results, this led to FDA breakthrough therapy
designation for avutametinib in combination with
defactinib. So when the makers of avutametinib and
defactinib first came to me and were interested in partnering on the
development of a registration-directed phase two study, I
was very excited to see this early efficacy data.
But we knew that there would be challenges and hurdles in the clinical
trial design.
So these two studies that I mentioned before, the GOG 281 study,
took more than four years to enroll 260 patients across
84 hospitals. And the MILO study took about three
years to enroll 300 patients across 102 different
sites in 20 different countries. So a lot of those sites
enrolled zero or one patient, and there was considerable use of
resources in order to complete that study.
So based on limited resources, we wanted to develop this phase two
study in the most efficient way possible and answer multiple
different questions at once. So this study is called the
NGOD-OV60 GOG 3052 RAMP 201
study, and we enrolled women with recurrent low-grade serous ovarian
cancer who had measurable disease and had received at least one prior line of
chemotherapy. Because
standard of care therapies are not very effective for this disease, we allowed
patients to have unlimited additional lines of therapy.
And patients were stratified by KRAS mutation status because we felt it would
be a potential biomarker for response to treatment and also because
we knew it was a prognostic indicator.
Patients with KRAS-mutant disease and low-grade serous ovarian cancer have an
improved prognosis versus KRAS wild-type patients.
And this study was really designed to answer three different questions.
In parts A and B of the study, patients were initially randomized to
treatment with combination avutametinib and defactinib versus
avutametinib as a single agent at a higher dose.
So this was really to look at the relative contribution of combination
therapy versus single-agent therapy.
It was found that the combination therapy had a higher response rate
and similar side effects to the single agent avutametinib.
Therefore, in the expansion regimen, part C, additional patients
were accrued to the combination therapy so that we would have more than 100
patients who had been treated with the combination dosing for
efficacy analysis.
And then in part D, the dose optimization cohort, we looked at a lower
dose of avutametinib, since a higher dose had already been examined in
parts A and B. It was found that a lower dose avutametinib in
combination with defactinib was suboptimal in terms of efficacy when
compared to the standard dosing.
During the course of this study, it was very important
to the makers of avutametinib and defactinib to try to receive orphan
drug designation. Now, we knew this would be difficult because this had
never been achieved for any drug trying to treat
low-grade serous ovarian cancer in the past.
And a huge part of ultimately achieving this orphan drug
designation was our patient advocates.
And so I have to credit Verastem for being incredibly involved with patient
advocates from the really beginning of this drug development
process. And we have Nicole Andrews here today, and so I don't want to speak to
this because she can speak to it so much better than me.
She did a wonderful job of mobilizing her community
to present a five-hour webinar about why drug
development for low-grade serous ovarian cancer was so important.
And this really spoke to the FDA and other stakeholders and ultimately led to
this orphan drug designation.
So we completed the study, and it showed unprecedented results for patients
with low-grade serous ovarian cancer, with an overall response rate of
31% and a response rate of 44% in those patients who had
a KRAS mutation. And what was really remarkable was the durability of
these responses, with a median PFS of 22 months for those
patients with a KRAS mutation and a median duration of response of
more than 31 months for the group overall.
So based on these results, Verastem submitted a new drug
application to the FDA in December of 2024,
requesting accelerated approval for avutametinib and defactinib
for patients with KRAS-mutant recurrent low-grade serous ovarian
cancer. This was granted priority review, and in less than
six months, accelerated approval was granted to the
combination of avutametinib and defactinib for women with recurrent
KRAS-mutant low-grade serous ovarian cancer.
So a huge achievement for our patients.
At the time of this approval, the confirmatory phase three study called the RAMP
301 study was about two-thirds accrued, because it was of course
important that we had substantially accrued to that study at that time.
Now, one of the considerations in this setting is, do you go for your confirmatory
phase three study in the same setting or an earlier line?
Because early line studies in ovarian cancer are very large and lengthy, we
did go for the same setting and so accrued to a similar patient
population, and again, stratified by KRAS mutation
status, and then randomized patients to the combination of
avutametinib and defactinib versus investigator's choice of
therapy.
Now, of note, the accelerated approval is specifically for the KRAS mutant
patients because those patients have the highest response rate and the highest
PFS, but these drugs do also show activity in the KRAS wild
type population. But we know that that's a poorer prognosis group
overall.So the Phase 3 design was designed with a
hierarchical statistical analysis to look first at the KRAS mutant
patients' PFS, and then to look at the overall population
PFS, with the hope that this confirmatory Phase 3 study
may potentially expand the approval to all patients with recurrent low-grade
serous ovarian cancer.
Now, one idea, of course, with drugs that look incredibly promising
for treatment of disease, especially a rare disease like this, we always want to
think about moving to the frontline setting as quickly as possible.
Now, for this particular drug combination, we chose not to go straight into a
large Phase 3 study looking at the frontline setting.
But we did want to move forward with seeing if this would be an efficacious
option to replace our standard of care for current first-line
therapy. So we chose to start an investigator-initiated
study at my institution, Sloan Kettering, that would look at those
patients that have the poorest prognosis, patients with newly
diagnosed low-grade serous ovarian cancer that's too extensive
for primary debulking surgery. These patients typically, unfortunately, have
very poor outcomes. And in this study, we allow these patients to be treated
with avutametinib and defactinib in combination with letrozole in the
hopes of potentially shrinking their cancer enough that they can go to surgery and
then remain on therapy. And this study is being performed right
now that we can hopefully develop a first-line study in the near future.
So in conclusion, breakthrough therapy designation, orphan drug
designation, and FDA priority review all enabled a
relatively small biopharma company to develop the
first ever FDA-approved treatment for women with low-grade serous
ovarian cancer. A dynamic Phase 2 study design allowed
for multiple questions to be answered efficiently in one study.
And very importantly, early and frequent engagement with patient advocates
helped drive trial design, encouraged patient accrual, and
supported orphan drug designation.
So just when speaking to our biopharma partners, I want to remind you to please
support rare tumor studies. It can be an efficient pathway for drug
registration. Thank you.
Thank you, Rachel. Next, we're going to have a panel discussion, and I'd like to
ask the panelists who haven't spoken yet to introduce themselves.
Denise, do you want to go first?
Hi, I'm Denise Reinke, and I'd like to first start by thanking Diane and
Martha for inviting Patient Advocacy Voice to this panel
today. I'm pleased to represent the sarcoma patient advocacy
community. I currently co-chair the Sarcoma Patient
Advocacy Global Network, which is a network of 70 sarcoma
patient advocacy groups from around the world.
I've also helped to found a sarcoma coalition, a group of
US-based sarcoma advocacy groups that come together to
help support each other, learn from each other, and to leverage their
strengths. And then most recently, I've been part of the organizing committee
of a group that's putting together the US Sarcoma Patient
Advocacy Partnership to really leverage and bring together
when we need to have a unified voice, whether it's for policy or
position statements that we can mobilize the community.
By way of background, I'm a sarcoma nurse practitioner.
I was also
one of the founding members and CEO of SARC, Sarcoma
Academic Research Consortium, and I'm delighted to be here.
Thank you.
Okay, Nicole, would you like to go next?
Everyone, my name is Nicole Andrews, and I am here
with STAR Low Grade Serous Ovarian Cancer Foundation.
And we are a patient advocacy organization
that works with
the LGSC doctors, researchers, industry,
and
we pull together the patient voice for the researchers.
We're also a funding agency to help fund the
research for low-grade serous ovarian cancer.
It's very underfunded. So we are happy to be here,
and I'm thrilled that drug development and program
futures is being
discussed and brought to the public.
Great. Thanks. Josh?
Hi, I'm Josh Link, honored to be here as well. I'm an oncologist by background.
I run a biotech company called Cheline Biosciences, and before that, I
worked at Eli Lilly, and before that I ran a clinical lab.
Okay. Thanks, everyone. Okay, so I'd like to start with a
question for everyone. So wanted to ask from your
perspectives as a patient advocate, pharmaceutical
designer, investigator,
could you say a few words about what you see as the most pressing barrier to drug
development for rare cancers?
Let's see. Eric. Actually, Martha, do you want to start, or should we
pass on to Eric first?
Wait, who do you want to start?
Did you want to say anything or-
I want to hear what everybody else has to say first.
Okay, yeah.
It's easy to be the first one, so you guys go.
Eric?
Sure.
We'll go in order. How about that?
Okay.
Yeah. The most
pressing need to me are twofold. One is, to me it all comes
down to understanding biology and what
can be targeted with an effective therapeutic window.
I think a lot of
efforts, I hope, are put to
putting together preclinical studies that, as best as it
can, tries to recapitulate the human condition and
evaluates toxicity in a way that could inform clinical trial
design. Because there's only so many shots on goal, only so many
patients. And so I think it starts there.
And I think, at least in my experience, the other major thing
isCreating a pathway forward. I
think
talking to industry collaborators, and I'll be curious to hear what Josh
says, is there's a de-risking that is required in
at least knowing what it takes, what is the goalpost.
And when you don't have a single drug approved for a disease, and you don't have
the goalpost, it makes it that much harder.
Thanks.
Yeah, I agree.
Really oftentimes rare tumors are actually more amenable to
targeted therapy since they're more likely to have a distinct driver alteration.
So really it's a great opportunity for drug development in so many
ways. But there is that risk because it's a smaller patient
population, so we worry about accrual goals and things like that.
And so I think as Eric was saying, once you get one FDA-approved drug for
your disease, I think it does de-risk it some.
It shows our biopharma partners that it can be done and there is a
pathway there. So I think that's very helpful.
And then it's just about, I think as researchers, it's our
job to work with our patient advocates, to work with our community, to show our
biopharma partners that we have the patients, that we can do the studies, that we
have the interest, and that we can make this happen.
And so I think, as long as we work together on those goals, we can show that it's
feasible.
From an advocacy perspective, I think that trial design is an
important component. Trials that are feasible for patients
and that have meaningful endpoints for patients, but also
they have to meet the bar from a regulatory standpoint of
being safe and effective, so kind of balancing that out.
But especially in sarcoma, where there are more than 100 different
subtypes, there are many ultra-rare sarcomas that we really
don't understand the biology of, and we don't understand the natural
history. And so really designing those trials are really impaired
also by not having that information in hand.
So those are the real barriers I see.
Nicole? Yeah. Yes, go ahead.
I would say,
again, from a patient advocacy
perspective in working with the industry,
researchers, FDA, approval
is very difficult. And that's where the partnership
is your double team coming in early and has
proven to be so successful, so that the thoughts on
endpoint, thoughts on quality of life can be it from the
beginning and discussed and not the later
after thought.
Yeah.
I agree with many of Rachel's
comments that
when you have the high probability of success, perhaps from a tight biology
story perspective,
when you have cooperative regulatory partners and patient advocacy
partners, a lot of really nice things about developing drugs in rare disease
populations. I think what large pharma,
which are often pacemakers in these things focus on are the,
not just trial completion and FDA approval, but how do the launches
go?
Mm-hmm.
And if the launches go well, they're going to be more of that, and if the launches
go badly, then they're going to scratch their heads a little bit.
I think about what are the barriers to maybe helping the launches go well.
And a lot of my
stumbling blocks that come to my head have to do with the actual companion
diagnostics
Mm.
... where
educational awareness
among the broad prescriber and patient community may be low.
The economic incentives for them to educate their patient both
before, after, and during the testing process.
There's reimbursement issues.
There are just a lot of barriers, and regulatory framework for CDXs
isn't the widest thing either. So I think if we could clean up maybe
the patient identification moment, I think that would help the launches
go well, which would help spur more interest
and more funding of rare disease .
Okay, thanks.
Denise, I wanted to ask you, how do you feel that patients and patient advocates
can improve our ability to evaluate benefit of a new
treatment in
study of rare cancers, in particular sarcoma?
Yeah, I think that patients
can really provide insight into the natural history of
the disease. They
have the connection,
as Nicole was saying, to their communities.
The
small subtypes have incredibly strong communities and
can reach out and gather that information that we
need to really understand the disease and understand
how they occur, the natural history, what their experience has been.
And
we've brought together
focus groups to explore what's really meaningful to them.
What are the most troublesome side
effects of the disease itself and symptoms that they experience,
that if that was mitigated, that that would really be important to them.
For many of the ultra-rare subtypes of sarcoma, we have no
treatments available at all. There's no standard of care, and so
therefore many times patients are feeling quite
isolated, and so they've been really mobilized to say, "We want to
share with you what our experience is so that we can help be a part
of finding opportunities to, yeah,
great, cure the disease, but my goodness, just even help us live with the
impact of this disease on our daily lives."
Thanks. Nicole,
kind of a similar question for you.
In her talk, Rachel described the importance of the advocacy community
in these trials and their success, and just wanted to ask for your
perspective on that.
Definitely what went
well...
development meeting, which is actually a US
FDA initiative that
allows
organizations like STAR, who represent a specific
patient group, so for our case, it was low-grade serous ovarian
cancer. And it's designed to be
led by the patient organization, but it allows patients
to come together and share their experiences
with patient disease, treatment trade-offs,
unmet needs, and they're sharing them with the
attendees that are researchers,
the regulatory groups, and industry, as
well as the patients themselves, and caregivers.
And doing so, actually, and the
follow-up is to the five-hour meeting that Rachel mentioned,
was an actual,
I like to consider it a handbook, but it exactly tells
what happened in the meeting, what did patients say, so that it can
be referred to. It rests not only on our
website but on the FDA website, so any future researchers
can go and understand, or industry, what did patients
say. What are their perspectives of
any treatment, and how it affects their quality of life.
And I do want to note, though I think that's very important to
mention, is the low-grade community is a very organized
community, and that helped us successfully hold
a patient advocacy,
extremely led patient-focused drug development meeting.
We had over 100 patients just in the meeting alone.
And because of our ability
to reach out to patients from around the world,
we're able to answer questions to the doctors, to industry very
quickly,
and mobilize when there's something that needs patient
input, patient participation. And that is a
huge benefit I would recommend always, with any rare
cancer, is to help that initial group begin to
mobilize.
Thanks.
Josh, I wanted to ask about, in your experience, what encourages
companies to decide to move into the rare cancer space?
The thing that's really bad for business is when your drug doesn't work.
And so I think the opportunity to see responses and to see a development
population that feels achievable, enrollable,
I think the main reason is just when they're associated with a higher probability
of success, I think that
gets everybody excited.
Thanks. And just to kind of follow up with that, right now
large scale diseases are in vogue,
autoimmunity, obesity.
What can we do to try and encourage
pharma to remember that
there's also
drugs to be developed
in the rare cancer space as well?
I'm no expert in
helping pharma out the things they don't want to...
Obesity and big market opportunities are in vogue, and I think there's a little
bit more appetite for bigger randomized Phase III binary
risks than there used to be, both in the halls of large pharma and in
investor circles. And
that's fine, because when those trials win, they help a lot of
patients. So the incentives are aligned there.
So I think what happens is when smaller drugs make it all the way, they
usually wind up having a partner
nonetheless. In other words, maybe they're not the object
of a lot of frenzy before the trial readout, or once a drug
is getting approved, there's usually somebody out there who wants to have that for
their sales force.
Okay.
So, I don't think they forget. So it's sometimes called a string of
pearls strategy, where you don't have the one big thing to sell, but you
have a bunch of things that all complement each other and
have very nice clinical packages with very receptive
patient communities, and prescriber communities.
And those are attractive
business models for pharma to embrace too.
Thanks.
Rachel, I wanted to ask you a little bit more about the RAMP 301 trial.
What aspects of the design made it attractive
to you as an investigator and
to patients? And in particular, if you could address
how the randomization and the control arm, that would be
great.
Yeah. So in the development of these drugs, we had initially
concerns about the ability to do a randomized Phase III study in a rare
patient population. We had seen the prior barriers
with the single agent MEK inhibitors, where with
low-grade serous ovarian cancer, we do have the advantage that's the opposite of
what Eric was describing for CMML, whereThe
incidence is low, and then the prevalence is also low because unfortunately, the
patients have a short disease period.
With low-grade serous ovarian cancer, it's a slower-growing tumor with a lot of
morbidity, so our patients, unfortunately, live with symptoms of their cancer for a
long time. But that does give us a large prevalence of patients in
order to be able to enroll to clinical trials.
And I think that was really important for us to
explain to our industry partners, because when you
hear that a disease only has an incidence of about
2,000 patients in the United States each year, it sounds like it
will not be possible to complete a randomized Phase 3
study. And it can be really difficult to get solid numbers on the true
prevalence of a disease. Oftentimes, that information isn't truly
available. And so we really have to talk to our investigators that treat
this disease to learn more about how prevalent the disease
really is.
And so ultimately, it was feasible to conduct a
randomized Phase 3 study in this patient population due to the disease
prevalence, due to the lack of competing studies, because there were no other
studies going on in low-grade serous ovarian cancer at this time, so that helped us
for sure. Due to early engagement with patient advocates, both
the RAMP 201 and the RAMP 301 study were incredibly
well-advertised studies. And I'm not talking about traditional advertisements.
There weren't any billboards or anything like that.
I'm talking about our patient advocates, boots on the ground, spreading the word.
And I had a huge number of patients that came to me, not referred by
their physicians, but referred by the patient advocacy
groups asking to enroll onto this clinical trial.
And so that was incredibly helpful for mobilizing our patients.
They came to me wanting this study because they had heard about these drugs and
were excited about it. And so I think all those things really came together
beautifully to allow for really rapid accrual, both to the
Phase 2 study and to the Phase 3 study.
I think another thing that helped was going straight from the Phase 2 study
into the Phase 3 study with minimal pause in
between, so that patients who had originally come in wanting to go on the Phase 2
study could just go on the Phase 3 study. Then we didn't lose any momentum there.
And of course, in the control arm, having investigators' choice, that always helps
because you have multiple options. You can enroll a larger number of patients.
And we did allow for crossover also.
And that was really important to our patients.
It's much more exciting to go onto a clinical trial if you know you'll still have
the opportunity for crossover if you're randomized to the standard of
care arm. And I see in a lot of Phase 3 studies now,
companies are nervous to allow for crossover because it will affect their overall
survival endpoint. But when I look at recently approved drugs in
gynecologic cancer,
oftentimes 45% to 70% of the patients ultimately
do crossover once the drug becomes clinically available, even though it wasn't
allowed in the study. And so, the majority of our patients, if it's a good
drug that gets approved, they're still going to get that drug later on.
And so I think we really do help our patients by allowing for
crossover, and I think the FDA understands that and takes that into
consideration when they're looking at the data.
Just one other thing I wanted to mention about a different rare tumor, granulosa
cell tumor. I had a very similar experience with that one, where we were
leading a large Phase 2 study in granulosa cell tumor, and
based on the rarity of that disease, the CRO had told the
company that they would need a
multi-country study, an international study
with 60 sites in order to accrue 40 patients to this study.
And I told the company, I was like, "I will be able to accrue to this study just at
my institution. I will accrue all the patients for you."
And we accrued 70% of the patients to that study in a very short period of time.
So I think it's really important to talk to your investigators, to
talk to your patient advocates, because these are the people who know the disease,
who know what's really happening, and I think it can be really informative in
developing your study design.
Thanks. Eric, just wanted to follow up with you on this.
From your perspective of CMML, where we haven't quite yet had
that successful study,
what's worked well so far and what needs to be improved?
Well, what needs to be improved is probably the
easier question to answer. And I think
one of the things that
I see that I'm encouraged by,
and I'm learning is so important, is this vague term
momentum. And I think in CMML now,
there is industry
appetite. There is patient advocacy groups that are
being formed. And so it's great to hear the story that
Rachel's telling because I feel like we're at the
beginning of that story, and it gives me a lot of hope that it'll
end like the story Rachel just told.
And so
there's a lot of
momentum, I feel. And one of the things
that I would say
I wasn't aware of was how
certain studies and certain decisions by us, by the
investigators, can change that momentum.
When you work on a rare cancer,
and a pharmaceutical company wants to work with you, you
almost say yes immediately.
But I think the right thing to do is, as I was
saying earlier,
really take the biology into consideration, take the feasibility
into consideration.
And even though they're rare opportunities, I think it's
better for the community, and I think it's better for our patients if
we try our best to choose those studies that are going
to continue to increase the momentum.
And hopefully, that's happening now in CMML.
I just wanted to comment that we had in sarcoma, there were
three large phase three studies that were done probably about five or six years
ago, and none of them met their endpoint.
And retrospectively, as everybody went back and said,
"What was wrong with this? All these patients, all this
money." And it was interesting. I'm glad to hear Martha talk about
people bringing all the stakeholders together, because it's this tension
where the company really has control over the design from a standpoint of
what they need to have the endpoint for approval.
The researchers may have had a different perspective, but
it was weighed in but wasn't always accepted.
And then at the end of the day, for some of the studies, it wasn't the right
endpoint. We didn't measure it properly.
And so I think that
it's just so disappointing. And then they didn't mandate
biospecimen or biopsies. And so then at the end of the day, a subset of
patients benefiting, we didn't know why they benefited.
And so all the effort to get a study up, running, going, I
think, reflecting on that, especially, it's really frustrating to
the patient community to finally have somebody be willing to
test their drug in their rare cancer, and now
we really didn't learn enough. We didn't understand why it didn't work
or why it maybe did work in some people.
So I think that kind of having more open
discussion,
really is imperative.
I just wanted to add to that. I wanted to echo those thoughts,
especially that about biospecimen collection.
So I was describing how important the preclinical biology is, but I feel
equally as important is the correlative studies,
those correlative studies that are done with the
right goal in mind. And so I feel like biospecimen collection is
a huge problem,
because as we all know, when we call a study negative, there's
still so much to learn from that study.
And without the biospecimens to understand why people are
benefiting, it makes it so difficult.
It slows the momentum to move towards the next step.
An example from
one of my former mentors, Alan List, in myelodysplastic syndrome,
where in the phase one study, the response rates were
not high, but they all happened in a specific genetic
subset of MDS. And ultimately, that led
and informed the next study, which ultimately led to its approval.
So I just wanted to emphasize how important I think it is to capture
biospecimens,
even in negative studies.
Yeah. Thanks. Is there time?
I think it's good. I see people want to have questions.
One more question.
Oh, I see. Open the question.
Okay. Yeah. Okay. So I'd like to open it to audience questions now,
or where people are getting their thoughts together.
I'd like to ask you... Oh, okay, go ahead, please.
Hi, Rob Hromas, UTL San Antonio. We're about to spin
out, after many years of effort, a pediatric sarcoma company.
We have a new agent for synovial sarcoma and a new agent for
infantile fibrosarcoma. They're degraders.
That's our med chem area of expertise.
I'm interested, Josh, in your business
model for
your rare disease drugs and how do you arrive at pricing?
And then the patient advocates, how do you advocate for pricing?
And how do we handle if you only have 300 patients, but only 200 of them
have insurance? How do we handle that 100?
And then
from the FDA standpoint, how does a priority review voucher help
with that business model? So Josh, and then the FDA, and
the patient advocates.
Well, fortunately, I didn't have to launch
the MEK inhibitor or the TRK inhibitor.
But
there are patient assistant
programs for the uninsured, obviously, you have to go off
the
price
I don't know if there's something clever to say, that the pricing stuff,
having watched a few rodeos
in the room and outside the room,
really, it's kind of like the Lake Wobegon, everybody's above average.
So if you look at the average pricing that's now the
norm in 2026 a month for use a month or the patient
month, and then you pick the median or you pick 75th
percentile of the pricing
bell curve, and that's why there's steady creep
upward. And it used to be that headline risks in the "New York
Times" kept everything honest, but now we're in a post Shane world, and
none of that applies anymore. So I think people just price
drugs the way their colleagues price these drugs with
steady markups. And people often back solve
the pricing model into a revenue goal they want to hit.
And this is an unfortunate truth about this,
is drugs that are slated to make less than $150
million a year in revenue, not profit, in revenue, are unlikely to be
capital funded.
Maybe you could get to that 100
barely, but just the fixed cost of
making a drug, launching a drug, doing post-marketing
surveillance of the drug, having people in the house that support the drug,
it's just an incident of pride. So there is this sort of
break-even number. When you get ultra-rare,
it's very hard to find a pricing model sometimes that allows you to
get over that one.
Do you want to
Hi, thanks for the question about the pediatric rare disease priority review
voucher.
At FDA, we have the luxury of not considering drug pricing, which I'm kind of
grateful for. We just have to look at the safety and effectiveness.
That being said,
when you look at the receipts for companies that have received
vouchers, there's been a kind of an up and down in terms of the monetary
value, the trade value. But I think they've ranged in the hundreds of
millions of dollar range. And so we see a lot of activity in
pediatric oncology and small biopharma, small companies.
I've been told by multiple people that does help the business proposition when
you're thinking about does this make sense or not?
It's important to realize your
product has to apply for rare pediatric disease designation for
the indications you're going for.
And then the original approval has to be for a rare
pediatric disease. But I do think, does it solve the problem? No.
But I think it does provide incentive for pediatric specific drug
development, not just for oncology, but outside of oncology as well.
So I am aware in Europe that the patient advocates get
engaged in discussions and provide input as
pricing is being set, but that's a whole different model,
especially like in the EU. I know from within the US, from a patient
advocacy perspective, the challenge and the financial
burden to patients to sort of finally have something available, but
then even if their co-pays are 20%,
it puts them in a category that they might not be able to afford the drug.
And that is just really
beyond frustrating and disappointing.
And so we have not gotten engaged in that
in sarcoma in the US, but I know as
we begin to be more organized as a community,
I think that-- And if we get more drugs approved, that would also
be of a great benefit. But
certainly, we recognize that financial burden, and it is
a concern to the community.
And I will just add to that, that I think in terms of sustainability and not only
having a drug approved, but making sure that it's viable and that it can continue
to be produced and marketed and made available to patients, I do think there are
definitely needs for new funding models, for creation of new
types of companies that can create sort of a
self-sustaining proposition, where maybe products that
have more profit potential are helping to fund things that don't have as much.
And there are a lot of really much smarter people than me working on that,
including where FDA is part of a partnership with
FNIH Project Ultra, that's looking at drug development for ultra-rare cancers.
And part of what we're hoping to do is help to create those
types of models that make it feasible and economically
feasible to make these products available to patients. We'll see.
If I could just say from a prescriber standpoint, so oral
therapeutics and gynecologic cancer cost on average, like $27,000 to
$42,000 a month for our patients now.
And obviously, it's not the patients that are paying that usually, that's the
cost. But when you put a drug
like that out there, you have to have a co-pay assistance program and a free drug
program. Because if you don't, I'm not going to tell my patient about a
drug and offer it to them and prescribe it to them if there's a chance that
then I'm going to have to say, "This costs you $20,000 a month."
That's not fair to the patient to put them in that position to say, "This is the
best drug for you, but now it's impossible for you to get it." So I
think as a model, you have to plan for the fact that you're going to have a co-pay
assistance program, you're going to have a free drug program for those patients
that don't have adequate insurance coverage so that the prescribers feel
comfortable prescribing the medication.
Mm-hmm.
Thanks. Go ahead.
Thank you. Lisa Lanister, CSO of Coastline Therapeutics.
Thanks for an engaging panel. I got two questions.
First one is to Martha.
Around the accelerated approval pathway, you said meaningful
advantage over available therapies.
Would really like to understand it a little bit more in rare disease space
where patients are a few. Would you expect head-to-head trials, or how would you
qualify the advantage over available
therapies? And my second question is to Eric, regarding the
endpoints. So in diseases where there is no precedent
of an endpoint when you have a heterogeneous disease, how do those conversation
with FDA upon sort of getting to agreement of what will we
accept as an endpoint, what is your experience in that and what evidence you should
put forward? Thank you.
Thanks for the question. A lot of accelerated approvals are in the relapsed
refractory space. You already have a situation where there aren't,
unfortunately, available therapies to compare to.
And in terms of when there are other available therapies to
compare to, that's often a conversation that we are having with
sponsors when thinking about their drug development program, and
their Phase 3 design, or Phase 2 often for rare cancers really becomes Phase
3. We have to blur, I think we should be blurring these designations
for Phase 2, Phase 3.
So
it depends, but things that we consider not only
are differential response rates, for instance, and durability.
We can also think about side effect profiles sometimes, although that
becomes a harder thing to compare in the absence of randomization.
And sometimes we think about ease of administration.
Is this an oral therapy that can be taken at home and not
a therapy that has to be administered in a hospital setting?
So I think there are different ways
to do that, and what we would prefer is these therapies that are getting
accelerated approval to be sort of...
changing, paradigm changing therapies.
The better the response is,
the more obvious it becomes. But we tend to not look at
accelerated approval. If there are products for the same
disease setting that have accelerated approval, we tend to not consider
those as available therapy until they've received traditional approval
as well. So, we do encourage early
discussions about this.
We often won't give a magic number, however.
Martha, I think that comes up as a question a lot.
In these rare tumors, oftentimes there are treatments that are compendium
listed but not FDA approved specifically for that indication, and whether they
have to be considered as a comparator arm, and it seems like they do
not because they're not FDA approved for that indication.
Sometimes if there are well-established
standards of care that don't have approval, we will sometimes still look at that
when it's very clear that those drugs are established and effective.
If we're discussing a randomized trial,
we want to be sure that the control arm is a
product that is appropriate for US patients.
Is this what we would consider reasonable for patients to receive in the
United States? Does this fit with standard of care?
It doesn't necessarily mean a specific drug.
Investigator's choice is a wonderful option in that case when it's
unclear what the standard of care really is.
People might, depending on the patient,
reach for different drugs in the armamentarium.
But that is something that we would really welcome early discussion
on. And I mentioned in my talk that we really welcome these
discussions early, because
sometimes when drugs work, things happen fast, and we want to be sure
that we're providing the advice at the right time so that you can
get the advice you need.
Yeah. So we have two more questions.
Just going to answer the question about endpoints.
In
CMML,
I mentioned the incidence is rare and the prevalence is short.
And in general, of course, that's an awful thing.
But in the context of endpoints, the silver lining is,
if your study is randomized, then it
is feasible to have an overall survival
endpoint. And so from the standpoint of a randomized study, and I
always go back, as we all do,
in terms of endpoints,
are we showing that patients live longer and are we showing
that patients feel better? And so,
the other endpoint that I think about in the randomized setting
is, of course, a PRO endpoint.
When we're talking about single-arm studies, it is a huge
challenge. I don't think I have a great answer
except to say that
focusing on those things that make patients feel better.
So,
things like, if you are getting transfusions
and no longer get transfusions, transfusion
independence, I think that there's a strong argument that you can say that's going
to make someone feel better. But I don't have a great answer.
If you don't have the pathway laid out, it's so hard
to say with confidence that this endpoint is the right one.
And I think it speaks to what Martha and Diane have said, which
is that
we need early discussions and early engagement with
regulatory agencies so we are on the same page.
But it is a huge challenge.
remarks remind me of a really interesting case study, which is fibrosis, where
volume reduction was
an endpoint. And it created an entire class of drugs that are widely
used as a rare disease model .
And it was from regulatory flexibility and
creative problem solving with the sponsor that led to the
drug. So I think it can be done, but it's a hard
one upward.
Well, and patient symptom score. I think there were two endpoints, right?
Yeah.
Splenic volume plus there was a composite patient symptom score, I believe.
Okay.
Don't quote me. But
the bottom line is the same.
When there isn't a
well-trodden path and it's not clear that response rate and
durability alone by resist are going to be the right
endpoints, that's when I think it's really important to hear from patients, like,
"What are the symptoms that are most important to you?" To hear from the
investigators, "What do you think is the most important thing?
What are you able to capture, even if it's not a resist endpoint, that may
help us understand how the drug is impacting the tumor, the
cancer?" And it's those type of discussions in the setting of a drug that
works that can lead to success, right?
Yeah. So over here at the right microphone.
Thank you. So I'm a GYN oncology fellow, so thank you, Dr.
Grisham, for presenting the background of the RAMP study, which is
so nice to have something like that
to counsel a patient with low-grade serous ovarian cancer, where we didn't have
that before. But my question is about the role
of studies that include
a larger
category of patients and that also include the
more rare tumors as kind of a bycatch.
So I'm thinking about how
we have dostarlimab for uterine carcinoma sarcomas, really because the RUBY
trial just happened to include 5 to 10% of that population
had carcinoma sarcoma. So I was just wondering if you could compare and contrast
the roles of the bigger studies versus the more focused studies and
what you think is
how
research is going to evolve in the future and how we
find treatments for rare cancers.
Maybe I'll speak to that first. I think that there's different pathways, right?
So for low-grade serous ovarian cancer, we did not have
an already approved therapy that we could latch onto and try to get
a compendium listing for. And so that's why this
registration-directed pathway was so important.
I think other times when there is a commercially available drug
already approved for another indication, the best bet in the United
States for our rare tumor populations is for us to run
studies that are more aimed towards compendium listing.
You don't need to do a registration-directed study for every single rare tumor if
you have a truly effective therapy that's already available and you
believe will benefit those populations.
And so, when we have a drug that's already approved for another
indication, I'm a big advocate for trying to run
efficient studies that enroll 40 to 60 patients with a rare
tumor that can show that benefit and potentially lead to compendium
listing. And so I think it really comes down to whether the drug
of interest is already approved or not, in my opinion.
Thanks. One last question over here.
Hi. Really nice discussion and panel. Thank you.
Isha Antani, Novartis.
One of the questions I had really for Eric and Rachel.
Eric, I love that chart that you showed about the therapies that have been
approved, like if tacopan. So taking the story of tacopan, it's
approved in PNH, but it also is approved in rare renal.
You have drugs that are going to come in autoimmune diseases that will be approved
for lupus as well as like ITP and Wiha.
So you see this biological convergence happening on pathways that have
implications in both heme, because I work in heme, so heme
malignancies, as well as like immunology or renal.
Do you guys convene or envision convening with
your counterparts in other therapeutic areas to think
about how to put this forward? Because sometimes that's often the best path
forward. So yeah.
It's such a good question, and I think you're spot on.
What comes to mind to me is, as you know,
there is a
now well-understood precursor state to these myeloid neoplasms,
and that is clonal hematopoiesis.
And in the last couple of years, we're learning how clonal hematopoiesis
impacts the tumor microenvironment in a way that makes therapy either
more or less effective. And so one possibility
and one thing we're exploring in our research, and I know many others are,
is if you can find therapies that augment that
effect of precursor condition on more larger
scale cancers, then perhaps that can be translated
to the fully manifested myeloid malignancy.
So that's one example that I know is something that we're all excited about is
understanding how the precursor state, which happens in about
30% of people with solid tumors and autoimmune diseases.
So I think we really have to leverage that precursor
condition.
Okay, thanks. So just to wrap things up,
I'd like to ask everybody for-
There's a-
Oh, take it.
Another question.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Go ahead.
My name is Elena Lee. I work for a biotech company.
I have a question regarding the two drug approval for the ovarian
cancer. Does the FDA ever ask the
contribution of a component?
Yeah. So in the first part of the Phase II study,
we looked at the combination of avotamgenib and defactinib
versus avotamgenib as a single agent at a higher dose.
Defactinib by itself has very little activity as a single agent.
So the real question was, is the defactinib adding to the
avotamgenib?
And so that was answered in the first part of the study,
by looking at the response rate for the patients treated with combination versus
single agent, and then also looking at the side effect profile of both arms.
So luckily, we were able to answer that relative contribution
question within the context of the larger study.
But both the drug are not approved any other indication before,
right?
Yes, that's correct, yeah.
And so that's why in this study, we had to show the relative contribution of
combination therapy versus single agent.
So you show the single agent are not so
efficacious with a low ORR, then
you show the combination has a better ORR, right?
Exactly. Better response rate and similar toxicity profile. Yeah.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
I think we've got about five minutes left. If not, probably not that.
Just a quick as a wrap-up, could everybody give just a quick
takeaway?
One thing you want us to take away from this
discussion.
I'll start. Just very briefly, to me, the most important takeaway
is
trials can be done. There is an incredible opportunity for rare cancers,
and 30% of all patients with cancer have a rare cancer.
So it's such an important topic to tackle, and I'm so grateful to the
FDA and ACR for sponsoring this.
Yeah, I think the FDA wants to work with us.
They want to get drugs approved. And so I think I agree.
The benefit of things like breakthrough therapy designation are that you get that
opportunity for earlier and more frequent meetings.
And so I think if you have the opportunity to do that, that's incredibly
important. And I think early engagement with your investigators
who treat the disease and patient advocates really can
help you make the most efficient study and help to
accrue to that study very quickly.
And I'll just echo that I think the most important thing is getting patients and
patient advocates involved very early on.
And beyond just saying their journey and the story
about their disease of an individual patient, but get the collective voice
of what is the
spectrum of experience, so that you can really fully
understand the diseases as the trials are designed.
And patient advocates, our community's becoming much more organized,
educating patients and patient advocates on
clinical trial research. They can help look at
inclusion, exclusion criteria. They can look at endpoints.
They can look at schedule of events, informed consents, and really trial
accrual begins at that very beginning.
If they fully understand, then we're in a good position to reach out
to our communities and help with accruing these studies or even get
those important biospecimens because we can help
educate them as to why this is so critical.
I would say exactly this. She just said that was perfect for
a patient advocate. Just being involved and
recognizing that patient advocates help in the
communication of all the components
that come to take a place, even down to how to
handle the side effects that may occur
within the design, and
bringing it back to the patient, but then to the doctor as
well, and to the industry. So
really keeping that communication open and
itself separate.
Something that I heard a little bit of on the panel was
that how success can beget success and how maybe failure can
dampen it. Eric mentioned an anecdote, and you
mentioned an anecdote. And I think the
investigator community
can and can be gatekeepers to the best ideas and be
pragmatists about the best trial designs and what are the meatier questions for the
physician I to know or maybe publication worthy questions.
And then when patient advocates in their communities
want to feel there's progress and be hopeful about, they
also in some ways have to be discriminating about whether that hope is being
well-placed because we don't want to dash it and set the whole field
back. I think we have a collective responsibility to find the most
compelling biology to commit to the most compelling trial designs to commit
to, and just go for it and to work it, being maybe a little
more circumspect when we have to visit.
Thank you. And this concludes the session.
Thank you all for being here. And thanks again to the panelists. Thank you so much.
Thank you.